Alright. Well we'd like to try to get an
understanding of how powerful one of these perceptron units are.
So, what is it that they actually do? So
they, they return, in this case either 0 or 1
as a function of a bunch of inputs. So
let's just for simplicity of visualization, let's just imagine that
we've got 2 inputs, X1 and X2. So Charles,
how could we represent the region in this input space
that is going to get an output of 0
versus the region that's going to get an output of 1.
>> Order the weights.
>> Right. So indeed, the weights matter. So
let's, let's give some concrete values to these weights.
And let's just say, just making these up that weight 1 is a half, weight 2 is a
half, and our threshold data is three quarters. So
now what we want to do is again, break
up this, this space into where's it going to
return 1 and where's it going to return 0.
>> Okay, so I think I know how to figure this out. So, there's kind of
an, there's 2 sort of extreme examples, so let's take a case where X1 is 0.
>> X1 is 0. Okay, good. So that's this Y axis, uh-huh.
>> Alright. So if X1 is 0, what value would X2 have to be in
order to break a threshold of three quarters? Well, the weight on X2 is a half.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So then,
the value of X2 would have to be twice as much
as the threshold which in this case is one and a half.
>> Right. So we're trying to figure out where is it, if X1 is 0, where
does X2 need to be so that we're
exactly at the threshold. So that's going to be.
>> Right.
>> The X2 times the weight, which is half has to exactly equal the threshold
which is three quarters. So, if we just solve that out, you get X2 equals
3 halves. So okay that's this point here. That's going to be
a dividing line. So anywhere above here, what's it going to return?
>> It will return, it will break the threshold, and so it will return a 1.
>> These are all going to be 1s and
then below this these are all going to be 0s.
>> Right.
>> Alright. Well now we have a very, very skinny
version of the picture. [LAUGH] Well what else can we do?
>> Well we can do the same thing that we just did except we can swap
X2 and X1 because, they have the same weight. So, we could say X2
equal to 0 and figure out what the value of X1 has to be.
>> Good, and that seems like it would be exactly the same algebra, and so
we get X1 is 3 halves, gives us at the one and a half point
above here are going to be 1s and below here are going to be 0s. Okay, so now
we've got 2 very narrow windows, but what we notice is that the relationships
are all linear here. So solving this linear inequality gets us a picture like
this. So this perceptron computes a kind of half plane right? So, so the half of
the, the plane that's above this line, the half plane thatt's above this line is
getting us the 1 answers and below that line is giving us a zero answers.
>> So Michael can we generalize from this, so
you're telling me then that because of the linear relationship
drawn out by a perceptron that perceptrons are always going to compute lines.
>> Yeah. Always going to compute, yeah
these half planes right. So there's a dividing
line where you're equal to the threshold and
that's always going to be a linear function
and then it's going to be you know, to the right of it or to
the left of it, above it or below it but its always halves at that point.
>> Okay, so perception is a linear function, and it computes hyperplanes.
>> Yeah, which maybe in
some sense it doesn't seem that interesting, but it turns out we're
already in a position to compute something fascinating. So let's do a quiz.